do both
i got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers mohammed love you guys
who wrote in
with
a struggle of what he should do next
with his life so here's what he said
hello sir i want to ask you a question
do you think that it's possible to work
on something that you're passionate
about say math even if it's not going to
be your job and still be sane while
doing something else say med school just
by believing really hard that you can
succeed in both of the areas because you
love them just that much mohammed
muhammad this is a fantastic question
and one that a lot of people wrestle
with i think everybody wrestles with
this at some point in their life you
know what do i do next should i take
this path or should i do this path or is
it a way to mix them all together and my
answer for you is do both
your success your real success your real
contribution to the world will come when
you can combine the things that you're
passionate about together so if you if
you're doing med school and you're
interested in that but and you really
love math your success your true success
will come by mixing them
med school and math that should be your
mentality and you'll create something
that nobody has created before because
there's a lot of math
in medicine right when you go off and be
a doctor or research or whatever you're
doing there could be a lot of math
involved and that's where you're going
to excel that's where you're going to be
amazing that's we're going to come up
with great new discoveries and it's only
until you combine those passions that
you're going to discover your true
genius and reach your full potential
where a lot of people
do the exact opposite they do what
you're talking about now you know
they're in this job it's okay you know
they got into it for some reason but
they have this really strong passion
that they just keep on their side right
so mathematics whatever it is and you
tinker and it gives you a little bit of
joy but the real success the thing that
makes you unique the things that keeps
you from being fired the thing that
helps you explode in your growth and
contribute something amazing to the
world is combining those two things
together that's what you need to do
mathematics and medicine those two
things together there's a great quote by
jim collins who wrote built alaska the
great he's an amazing author and he said
embrace the genius of the and where most
companies will say we could do this or
we can do this
you know we can make it high quality or
we can make it low cost
and most people think the same way i
could take this path or i can do that
path and right there just by framing the
question
you look at the question that you asked
me right there and how you framed it
you've already set up a limiting
personal belief you've already closed
yourself off to options because you
think you have to do this one or this
one
there doesn't exist a world a reality
where both of those things work together
and that's where the genius comes out
that's what jim collins was saying
embrace the genius of the end do both
things together be the one person that
combines those to be unique and unlock
your genius that's where your happiness
lies that's where your money lies that's
where your potential lies that's where
your impact on this world lies
do both
and embrace the genius of the end
belief
for those who watching like the video
subscribe to the channel you'll see more
videos just like this thank you so much
for watching i'll see you soon